I want people to hear my
voice no and just forget their troubles
for 5
minutes do you know what girl power
means to meet Sarah Bourn Lauren Hill
you need to know this I ain't no SP
scale from primary
school to sell out
concerts it's going to happen one of
these days Bo like yours got to it's one
of the best I've ever heard that's my
daughter that's my Amy I met someone
tonight stay
lucky got an i for the bad
boys the album's number one around the
world the highest chatting album from a
British female artist in the
US ever
[Applause]
W I don't think I was put on this Earth
just to sing me I want to be a wife I
want to be a
mom probably run off of someone famous
anyway you're my heartbeat you're my
soul I love you
tears I don't bang out tenants by lunch
I need to live my songs so that's what
I'm going to go and do
ready
we
only I don't write songs to be
famous I write songs
cuz I've got to make something good out
something
[Applause]
bad